the endorsement of a global rock star is
what political parties dream of Sir Rod
Stewart made Labor's day with this
unexpected call to Sky News I personally
have been a touring for a long time and
I think this government should stand out
now and give the labor party a go at it
within a day Labor's leader and Deputy
were visiting the local hospital and Sir
Rod's Essex constituency to hear from
nurses and ambulance staff is this a
turning point in Labor's fortunes I'll
go along for a sing-along with Rod
Stewart and thank him for his words
yesterday I think he actually reflected
a mood across the country which is who
so much is broken and not working and I
think it's a real frustration that
things have been brought to this point
by the government here in conservative
voting Harlow some have already changed
their minds I agree with Rod I think we
should go labor now yes I do I've always
been a Tory voter and
but at the moment I understand my I'm
sort of a bit swaying because of the NHS
the Health Service is one of them and
then before that the the party gate
scandals and you name it you know and I
think it's time for a change now if
labor
with the current government voters still
need more convincing that labor would do
things differently
at this Farm Shop a stone's throw from
Sir Rod's home others weren't so sure I
think we had brexit we've had kovitz
you've had the issues with the Ukraine
um and I think it's just been like a
massive explosion so I think we need to
give him that chance to see if he can
put things back on the right track the
local conservative MP hopes others will
give the government the benefit of the
doubt celebrities will have different
views there are some celebrities who
support conservatives some celebrities
who support the labor party but what Rod
Stewart and others will want to know is
that to get the the government is
spending record amounts on the National
Health Service a lot of Voters are very
understanding they know that we've been
through three years of our awful
pandemic kirst armor is hoping to hit
the sweet spot with voters who have
drifted away over many years this
unexpected boost has given his party
reason to believe tomorrow Co and Sky
News Harley thank you